madame le premier ministre bonsoir je
vous remercie de nous recevoir chez vous
au 10 downing street et de participer
ainsi à cette émission d'antenne de
cartes sur table exceptionnel
exceptionnelle à cause du moment pour
l'europe du climat international et de
votre personnalité
depuis 10 mois vous gouverner ce pays la
grande bretagne
mais si les européens entendent souvent
parler de vous et de votre politique
c'est la première fois que vous vous
adressez ainsi directement à eux et en
particulier ils savent que vous le ferez
franchement parce que vous avez la
réputation de dire toujours ce que vous
pensez et c'est pourquoi il attend à
trois semaines du prochain sommet de
bruxelles que vous définissiez les choix
et les propositions de l'angleterre
la rumeur monte en effet d'une prochaine
grave crise en europe dans la grande
bretagne et vous-même seriez au centre à
cause de la contribution de la grande
bretagne au budget de la communauté
alors la première question alain duhamel
oui madame il ya justement à paris un
mystère à votre sujet
comment peut-on être à la foire une
bonne britannique bonne européenne est
une bonne amie des américains
aubenas causse mais via sur le monde
occidental a les mêmes intérêts
c'est-à-dire la défense de notre mode de
vie libre bien sûr nous devons rester
ensemble n'est pas si tard et c'est deux
points de vue c'est la base même de la
science occidentale
il n'y a pas de problème là en
définitive nous dépendons de la garantie
que donne l'amérique à notre sécurité en
europe et les américains ne peuvent se
passer nous donc je m'empare que l'on
s'efforce de les dissocier
eh bien peut-être les différences
mineures rendre nous mais elle son petit
comparé à ce qui nous unit cependant
pour les français depuis vous êtes
premier ministre on a l'impression que
la grande bretagne est plus critique
peut-être même destructrice et en tout
cas négative surtout les premiers
européens est plus attiré à nouveau vers
le grand large
quand un problème se refait un mais
voyez ce qui contribue l'ont alors par
exemple les sécheries 60% des pêcheries
proviennent legrand brossard nous avons
un bon potentiel commercial pour
l'europe
après tout l'europe exporte beaucoup
plus vers la grande bretagne que vice
versa nous sommes à un marché très
précieux pour les européens
et puis si vous emmenez homogène nous
apportons la contribution la plus
importante de ce seul et c'est là un
problème et la situation était renversé
entre la france et la grande bretagne
6 la grande-bretagne contribuer
seulement 700 millions de francs
français à la france une flotte de
france est ce que la france serait pas
la première à s'en plaindre dire que ce
n'est pas c'est le contraire qui se
produit la france est beaucoup plus
riche que nous et je vous en félicite
nous la france contre 2 700 millions
nouveau front à la communauté et le
environ 9 millions de francs français le
feu bien entendu le 10 ans n'est pas
équitable bien sûr nous pensons qu'il
faut régler cette question il faut la
régler
alors justement puisque nous en arrivons
à la crise de l'europe et la préparation
du sommet qui va avoir lieu à la fin du
mois et qui sera très important
ce que font les français voudraient
savoir madame cécile voulu l'aborder
dans un esprit de compromis et de
conciliation et si oui quelles sont les
nouvelles propositions que la
grande-bretagne est prête à faire ce
problème dans un esprit véritable elles
seront remis mais nous avons peu de
marge de manoeuvre
le savez gamelle sur le revenu par
habitant de sochaux dessus du niveau
moyen communautaire n'est pas
raisonnable que le soyons les gros
contributeur aux deux chais nous ne
cherchons pas à éluder une
responsabilité voulons faire une
contribution raisonnable oui mais il me
semble absurde que nous ne sommes pas
raisonnable l'allemagne contribuent de
façon importante et à la communauté
ce n'est parce que l'on verse à la
communauté nous connaissons leurs
ressources du système
la difficulté c'est que une fois comme
accusée et il ya un problème de
restauration des fonds budgétaires et
les autres guérilleros c'est bien
davantage
j'aime alors que nous manifestions vous
allez faire quelles propositions quelles
suggestions
la grande bretagne va t'elle fait ses
véritables positions comme règle et se
dégagent deux derniers sommets table un
regard des trois propositions d'abord
une modification des contributions qui a
été accepté dans l'ensemble nous avons
réglé cette question
deuxièmement au plus une centaine qu'ils
nous de faire en sorte que le niveau de
recettes donc en bretagne soit nettement
plus élevé qu'à l'heure actuelle deux
car nous avons prévu des recettes et
l'essentiel des contributions et sont
repartis à l'intention des autres pays
membres en europe
manifestement nous sommes tous prendre
des recettes de la communauté dans des
domaines qui sont d'intérêt
communautaire sur le terme
infrastructures cab affreux c'est à dire
sur les constructions vont les rues les
zones de danger il y a beaucoup de
chemin hlm et d industrie où il ya
beaucoup de changements à 6,8 et
contournant du siècle a donc le pouvons
consacré leurs recettes dans un esprit
comme le ter c'est que nous devons nous
efforcer de restructurer ses plaies
parce que sinon des dépenses au monde
elle que l'on se heurtera au plafond du
budget
en somme vous demander davantage
d'argent pour la grande bretagne et vous
pensez que la grande bretagne doit tant
donné - à l'europe
et vous pensez qu'en ce qui concerne vos
vies partenaires européens
ils doivent peut en recevoir - et en
donner davantage
les contributeurs les plus importants au
budget européen
bien que notre but soit inférieure à la
moyenne européenne
je ne connais personne qui trouve que ce
soit équitable ce n'est pas équitable et
dépenser qui table d'être le
contributeur le plus important prend le
revenu est inférieur à la moyenne
nous sommes stupéfié que l'on ne dise
que la grande bretagne peut contribuer
le plus cela nous donne une idée de la
communauté c'est que les contributions z
soit lorsque nous avons adhéré à la
pomme de terre l'un d'entre eux veut
annuler si des conditions se produisait
qui rendra inacceptable la participation
est d'un nombré faudra alors examiner et
ce n'est pas acceptable par conséquent
il faut entre partenaires que nous
examinons la situation je ne
m'attendrais parce que la france soit le
plus gros contributeur
si son revenu et est inférieure à la
moyenne communautaire
je vous assure que vos politiciens
français les plus distingués se plaindra
si c'était le cas
et pourtant l'image de la
grande-bretagne c'est que vous attendez
presque un traitement de faveur et des
cadeaux de la part de l'europe et les
européens attendent vivement favorable
recherchons un traitement équitable
c'est l'aimable la même chose
nous ne demandons pas la charité
beaucoup de pays bénéficient de leur
participation à l'europe
nous n'avons de bénéfices et nous ne
demandons pas à être les bénéficiaires
nets selon l'espace la charité disons
simplement que nous pourrons pas
continuer à contribuer de façon aussi
importante
je voulais dire entre temps beaucoup à
l'europe il y à un seul devant nous
c'est une ressource commune
il y avait 90 matière c'est le pôle dont
60 % provient des eaux britanniques nous
sommes un gros marché pour les produits
fins industrielles et les produits
agricoles français la grande bretagne
sera beaucoup plus d'importations
française que le contraire n'est vrai
par conséquent nous sommes très généreux
dans nos contrées gestion et nous ne
demandons pas la charité
mais si la grande-bretagne effectivement
cette année doit être un grand
contributeur en europe c'est d'abord
parce que comme elle est entrée dans le
marché commun après les autres pays elle
importe hors du marché commun davantage
que les autres
autrement dit c'est de sa faute à elle
et pas celle de ses partenaires est ce
qu'on lui demande c'est en fait
d'appliquer la réglementation européenne
ce n'est pas une punition c'est la règle
normale avec tout le respect que je vous
dois je vous dit que les contributions
sont selon les règlements selon la vague
mais il y a deux formes de contribution
ce n'est pas seulement ce que l'on
apporte à la communauté c'est aussi la
façon dont les fonds de la communauté
sont répartis et ils ne sont pas
répartis dans le sens de la grande
bretagne dans la mesure où ils devraient
l'être c'est en partie création de la
façon de la politique agricole a évolué
on avait dit on va voir de notre
adhésion que l'on s'attendrait à ce que
je sois 55 à 60% du budget maintenant
c'est plus de 75%
c'est du cousu également la façon dont
cette politique est appliquée car ce
n'est pas raisonnable et que nous
entretenions toujours à l'accumulation
d'excédents énorme les dépassent de loin
nos besoins ainsi nous payons deux fois
nous payons des prix élevés pour les
produits alimentaires que nous
consommons et nous payons également sous
forme d'imposition pour les excédents de
nous n'avons pas besoin des repas
raisonnables pour quelque pays que ce
soit ce que madame la logique de
démarche la grande bretagne s'est pas au
bout du compte une remise en cause de la
politique agricole commune est peut-être
la mort de cette politique quelle
comédie
non je ne pense pas que nos dix on sait
qu'à moi que la politique locale mahmoud
soient modifiées elles se heurtent rhin
au plafond budgétaire car les montants
augmente d'année en année ce que je
démissionne
gamache c'est que cela n'a pas de sens
quel que soit votre pays d'origine
qu'une grande partie de votre budget
soit consacré à accumuler des excédents
que personne ne peut consommer et qu'il
faut ensuite landreau pays d'outre-mer à
des prix plus bas que ceux qui sont
perçus dans les pays du marché commun
cela n'a pas de sens et la communauté
doit être raisonnable et doit être
équitable entre partenaires nous
demandons un traitement équitable sic
et si vous n'obtenez pas on voit très
bien ce que vous demandez à la
communauté ce qui serait intéressant si
c'est de savoir ce que vous pouvez lui
apporter alors pour les français par
exemple il ya une question qui se pose
c'est ce qui concerne le pétrole est ce
que le pétrole britannique est un
pétrole européen
ou est ce qu'il est un pétrole comme
sont des pétroles et pétrole des pays
arabes
autrement dit est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
une préférence européenne sur le pétrole
britanniques contribuent à la pomme
d'invités en ce moment nous apportons la
contribution la plus importante à la
communauté le demandons de contribuer
loi sont des demandons d'en tirer des
bénéfices simplement de contribuer -
nous sommes les panthères le plus
important pour le poisson et pour les
marchés maintenant vous parler du
pétrole devenu le jamais demandé à la
hollande si leur gaz naturel appartient
la communauté vous n'avez jamais posé
cette question aux pays bas
c'est une ressource rare il n'y a pas de
ressources encore vu mais ça pour le
poisson pour le pétrole nous sommes même
case encore capable de couvrir nos
propres besoins et par ailleurs nous
avons des exportations importantes à
effectuer parce que ce n'est pas le type
en cas de fuite de pétrole à cause de
son titre en jeu élevé elles ne devront
acheter du pétrole brut environ 50 % de
nos exportations sont à destination de
la communauté
nous avons relevé les prix très
lentement nous avons suivi les hausses
de prix mais de loin n'avons jamais
inaugurait des hausses de prix 50 % de
pétrole de la mer du nord sont déjà
exporté à destination de la communauté
pour acheter maintenant d'un malentendu
la grande-bretagne et d'un contributeur
très important la communauté pour le fil
ans pour le choix sion pour le marché
c'est un partenaire très important et
elle veut le rester lève elle veut et
devrait avoir un traitement équitable
imaginez que l' inverse produisent que
ce soit le président giscard on le
général de gaulle
ils iraient aux barricades et luttera
pour que la france soit traité
équitablement il demanderait qu'on nous
traite ainsi et alors c'est le cas du
temps mais parlons je vous revenez à
nous si si vous n'obtenez pas
satisfaction dé bruxelles
est ce que il faut envisager une rupture
avec la communauté européenne
un départ une sécession ou es ce que
vous avez des mesures de représailles
par exemple vous avez menacé de ne payer
qu'une partie du budget de votre
contribution est ce que vous le ferez
il n'y a pas de possibilité que la
grande bretagne qui le marché est calme
à la communauté du martyr des grands du
monde libre et le monde libre vouloir
vivre ensemble dans l'alliance la plus
efficace qui soit possible le monde y
est évident une à lyon une zone qui est
par des liens louis m'a forcé la nôtre
d'une alliance libre et elle doit être
efficace il le sera de question que nous
quittions la commune offre des moments
là ce n'était pour être efficace et sans
que l'un des principaux pays d'europe
occidentale en partie ce serait très
vieux pour la paix et pour chacun de ses
membres que la grande-bretagne petit
marché comme un seul nom et nuit sans
rejoindre et dans l'est donc pas
question s'il n'y a pas de compromis dès
cette conférence de bruxelles quel
calendrier qu'est ce que vous prévoyez y
avoir un règlement de la question car la
position est tout à fait inéquitable je
répète les chiffres la france apporte au
budget de la communauté 10 700 millions
si les autres et 9000 certainement la
france faudra rectifier cet équilibre
que ce n'est pas le rejet est dû à son
honneur de la news avons transmis nos
négociations et la grande bretagne
doivent être traités avec justice à
moins qu'on nous traite équitablement
bientôt ce serait difficile de faire des
programmes car nous pensons que nous
devrions faire des progrès sur les
questions qui nous concernent
mais concrètement si vos huit
partenaires continentaux dont ils en ont
une autre idée que vous de la justice
autrement dit si à l'issue du prochain
sommet européen il n'y a pas d'accord
entre la grande bretagne et les huit
autres partenaires du marché commun
concrètement que fait la grande bretagne
je doute vraiment que ceux-ci se
produire car déjà certains des pays
membres seront la situation n'est pas
équitable et si c'était fait fondamental
on ne peut pas continuer entre
partenaires à avoir une inégalité de
base je ne m'attends pas à ce que les
autres pays souffrent en silence
je pense que vous n'êtes pas juste du
tout en un sens ce vis-à-vis de certains
de nos autres partenaires à dublin un
certain nombre de nos bas mr ont insisté
que nous devrions continuer à faire des
efforts car ils se rendent compte que la
valeur de la communauté et que le monde
libre qui vivent ensemble ils se rendent
compte que je n'ai pas seulement un
problème économique en grand mois d'un
dieu sait que nous avons tous des
problèmes économiques y compris la
france en ce moment mais nous avons un
problème politique très important car
les gens disent pourquoi devrions-nous
contribué au temps et être aussi
maltraités donc je ne pense pas que
s'ils se produisent
or je crois que vous n'êtes pas juste
vis-à-vis des autres pays européens
lorsque vous dites qu'il mette pas prêt
à considérer une rectification de cette
situation que nous ressentons
profondément vous attendez un compromis
avez vous dit tôt ou tard mais dès cette
année dès le sommet de bruxelles où
serez-vous patiente et l'autre parent
si vous permettez cette affaire est une
affaire européenne
il semble qu'elles prennent l'image
d'une querelle d'un conflit franco
britannique pourquoi est ce que c'est
normal non non mais j'espère que cela ne
prend pas les murs d'un dissentiment
entre la grande bretagne et la france
c'est un problème comme de terre nous
contribuons à la communauté dans son
ensemble et la communauté ne distribue
pas assez de ressources à nouveau
j'espère que cela ne prend pas la l'urd
un problème franco britannique
la france a un revenu plus élevé que le
nôtre par habitant et nous pensons que
nous devrions contribué mois que la
france en contribution nette de
questions la première est ce qu'il ya
une chance que la grande-bretagne
accepte désormais de participer cette
année au système monétaire européen sme
bien entendu nous étudiants cette
question nous l'avons étudié à fond
comme vous le savez notre vie la volonté
des cendres lorsqu'elle n'est pas
directement rattachée la performance
commerciale de la grande bretagne il ya
d'autres facteurs en jeu qui affectent
ses fluctuations
depuis ma venue au pouvoir elle aurait
complètement quitté le niveau
une limite européenne elle est allée à
2,2 de l'affronter 1,2 dollar 0,6 et ce
sont là des sources de difficultés
importantes pour nous une seconde qu'il
commet comment expliquez-vous que en
particulier depuis que vous êtes premier
ministre britannique
l'ensemble de la presse britannique
considère que la france est le méchant
pays européens et que symétriquement de
plus en plus une bonne partie de la
presse française considère aussi que la
grande bretagne est le méchant élève de
la classe européenne
je n'ai pas de contrôle sur la route
face à danic c'est sûr que vous ne
contrôlez pas la pression ses concorde
ensemble qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
choses que nous pouvons faire ensemble
après tout la france une force de frappe
indépendante et 12 ici-même rappelons
l'objectif essentiel de la communauté
c'est que l'europe liban puisse vivre
ensemble
c'est l'objectif principal de l'alliance
occidentale que le monde est libre
puisse montrer que nous avons le
meilleur mode de vie et le plus prospère
dans l'ensemble c'était l'objectif
principal dont il ne faut pas se laisser
détourner par des petites divergences
gladio avoue je crois six matches six
vous n'avez pas de compromis cette année
et dès le mois de mars à bruxelles
est-ce que vous pratiquerez à la de
gaulle la politique de la chaise vide
est ce que vous bloquerez le mécanisme
des institutions et que pensez vous de
ceux qui en france et en allemagne pense
que finalement il serait préférable que
vous soyez un membre associé de la
communauté plutôt qu'un membre plein
plutôt que membre à part entière
pourrait commencer par votre dernière
question est ce que la combattante de
votre un membre associé nous sommes pas
bons à part entière et nous voulons le
rester
l'europe serait très gravement affaibli
si nous cessions d'être violement à part
entière il vaut mieux nous soyons à part
entière pour la grande bretagne et pour
l'europe
est-ce que j'adopterai la politique de
la chaise vide le général de gaulle
lorsqu'il pensait que la france n'était
pas très supportable le mans la basicité
a glissé jusqu'à ce soir rectifier je ne
pense pas que vous puissiez adopté le
style de quelqu'un d'autre
général de gaulle même si la chaises
étaient vides étaient présents parce que
c'était quelqu'un de tout à fait
remarquable
je crois que moi même et mes ministres
serions plus efficace si nous étions
présents à notre plan simone réunion
parce que nous voulons être traités
équitablement nous y avons droit
reçoivent les autres partenaires le
rendront à nos classes nous resterons
dans nos chaises et nous continuerons à
défendre nos droits
oui dans tous les débats au sein de la
communauté ne voulons que ces
déséquilibres soit rectifié au cours de
l'année financière à venir
il faut que cela continue dans les
années à venir parce que les
déséquilibre s'accentue d'une année à
l'autre alors sur un autre sujet madame
pendant son voyage au moyen-orient le
président valéry giscard d'estaing a
pris deux positions importantes
la première c'est en faveur de
l'autodétermination du peuple
palestinien
la seconde c'est en faveur de la
participation de l'ol paie à une
négociation pour régler les problèmes du
moyen-orient par jour à savoir si vous
du même avis que le président français
et si oui si vous pensez qu'il doit y
avoir une prise de position européenne
dans le même sens
il y avait une position exposée aux
nations le président irlandais côtés des
présidents
je crois que l'expression cette
autodétermination avait été a employé
jusqu'à première fois qu'on a parlé
d'auto détermination mais la conception
blot gaz est convenu dans le cadre
général d'un règlement du moyen orient
on s'attendrait à ce que le peuple
palestinien puisse déterminer leur
propre avenir
mais la contrepartie de l'autre côté
doit être que le bleu et que le peuple
palestinien reconnaisse le droit
d'israël à exister dans des frontières
sûres
la difficulté c'est de réconcilier ces
deux incidents il ya un autre facteur
lancement d autodétermination pour le
peuple palestinien
s'il faudra qu'ils aient eu l'idée
qu'elle compte des choix qui leur sont
ouverts il faudra donc qu'il y ait des
débats sur la question pour mieux
connaître les possibilités alternatives
mais le président a dit long sur la
décision
il faut que l'hôte de leur médiation
avec un engagement et une compréhension
de la part du peuple palestinien il y a
à droit à l'asile à part d'israël est un
droit à des frontières sûres
après l'iran après l'afghanistan vous
avez réclamé le boycott des jeux
olympiques
vous avez réclamé toute sorte de
l'embargo est donc une politique de
fermeté sk pas une contradiction à
réclamer en même temps une poursuite de
la politique de détente avec l'union
soviétique
la détente ce drame à 200 c non pas sens
unique et ne faut pas que nous
continuons à donner
alors que l'union soviétique se comporte
comme s'il n'y avait pas de détente la
détente ne consistera à ce qu un pays
quelconque envahissent le territoire
d'un autre peuple indépendant et
continue à prétendre que la détente est
poursuivi la détente de être à double
sens
c'est ainsi que nous la concevons et ce
n'est pas ainsi semble-t-il que l'union
soviétique la conçoit pourquoi ce que le
prendre son train dit nettement à
l'encontre des jeux olympiques à moscou
que les troupes soviétiques le beurre en
afghanistan qu'elles sont envahis locaux
considèrent ces questions de façon
beaucoup plus politisé que je vous avais
vu sans doute certains des documents du
parti communiste à mesure où ils
maintiennent que les jeux olympiques se
tiendront à moscou pour plus sur indiqué
que l'on apprécié et approuve la
pourtant deux millions de victimes et la
justesse de sa politique internationale
je ne voudrais pas que nos athlètes
aille à moscou pour indiquer la
politique étrangère de l'union
soviétique alors qu'ils ont envahi
l'afghanistan après tout l'objectif des
jeux olympiques est une réunion dans la
france comme pays hôte indélicat envahi
un territoire étranger
mais si les soviétiques font un geste
diplomatico-militaire ce que vous
reconsidérer votre position sur les jeux
olympiques
il faut que l'union avait été quitte
l'afghanistan y les troupes sont sur le
territoire d'un état indépendant on ne
peut pas dire que ce soit un état de
paix c'est vraiment l'une des choses les
plus grands qu'un pays puisse faire
c'est envoyer le territoire d'un état
indépendant
comment peut-on dire que cela va dans le
sens de l'inter bien sûr que non c'est
l'union sovétique se comporte ainsi
sentir que fera t-elle ensuite nous
sommes déjà passés par là vous savez
vous menez en grande-bretagne même une
politique économique qui est une
politique très énergique
les résultats pour l'instant ne sont pas
toujours très évident et vous êtes de ce
fait critiqué à la fois par votre
opposition travaillé par les syndicats
et par une partie des conservateurs est
ce que vous êtes sur la bonne voie vous
avez un changement essentiel c'est un
changement essentiel les font un peu de
ton il faut du temps pour contrôler
l'inflation parce qu'il ya un décalage
dans le temps entre la mise en oeuvre
des politiques et leur application
efficace lorsque vous avez un déficit
elle
et alors que l'on vit là de ses moyens
lorsqu'on emprunte de plus en plus
chaque année
il faut du temps pour réduire les
dépenses et les emprunts on ne peut pas
le faire sans difficulté sans problème
par conséquent il faudra du temps pour
rétablir la situation
mais la seule autre possibilité c'est de
continuer une politique qui dans une
année aboutirait à une augmentation de
l'inflation et qu'ils n'aboutiraient
jamais à ce que l'argent le capital soit
dans le secteur productif dont nous
avons besoin c'est une nouvelle
politique c'est une politique vital
c'est également une politique qui
consiste à dire vous ne devez pas vous
tourner vers le gouvernement pour
remédier à tous vos mots nous vivons en
démocratie la démocratie consiste à ce
que les gens deviennent responsables de
leurs propres actions
graduellement je crois que nous
l'emporterons
les gens sont en assumer leurs
responsabilités de plus en plus la
direction des affaires aux dirigeants d
entreprise et les changements sont plus
importants en profondeur qu'en surface
c'est très encourageant que certains ne
soient pas prêts à faire la grève se
reconnaissent qu'ils ont le devoir de
s'occuper de leur famille
nous sommes certains que tous ceux
réussira à long terme et que nous
suivons la bonne voie on dit souvent
autour de nous que vous avez beaucoup de
tempérament un tempérament bagarreur où
vous avez du caractère si nous le voyons
on vous présente mal à me sentir comme
une guerrière qui ne redoute pas
l'impopularité
est ce que un premier ministre doit pas
être aussi peut-être aimé est en tout
cas être un facteur d'unité
je l'espère mais j'étais asos de riz en
province l'autre jour j'ai marché dans
les rues c'était une occasion vraiment
très émouvante
les gens ont réagi de façon vraiment
merveilleuse cela m'a beaucoup encouragé
v2g une tâche très difficile je le
reconnais puis ils sont quelqu'un de
très déterminé de très résolus ne et des
nerfs d'acier
nous avons à effectuer des changements
très considérable mais apprécions tout
le monde ils s'attendent à ce que la
grande bretagne soit ferme et résolu je
ne crois pas l'une veut est quelqu'un de
moins résolu ce mois en outre monsieur
elkabbach
les politiques sont six à se centrer sur
le court terme as le et les solutions à
coderre je me rappelle avoir lu ce de
bastia un texte excellent de sébastien
historique aux français qu'on nommait
spatiale est que david france m santé
qui disait que très souvent quelque
chose qui semble à court terme est
réglée situation avoir à les effets
l'auzance à long terme
je veux dans une bonne solution à long
terme et cela implique des difficultés
dans le court terme et nous
l'emporterons
car j'ai une politique à long terme qui
est impliqué nous allons dans une autre
direction et c'est la bonne direction je
ne me laisseraient pas détourner une
dernière question madame quand vous
trouvez un sommet européen
en étant la seule femme la seule
britanniques est un des plus jeunes est
un des plus récents premier ministre en
face des autres chefs de gouvernement et
du chef de l'état français qu'est-ce qui
est le plus difficile à surmonter le
fait d'être une femme
le fait d'être britannique ou le fait
d'être premier ministre depuis peu de
temps encore je m'aperçois part que je
suis une femme je suis là comme premier
ministre à je ne trouve pas qu'il soit
difficile d'être ne vous font pas senti
non non d'une fugue mais n'oubliez pas
que j'ai des années et des années
d'expérience de formation scientifique
et comme je ris
par conséquent j'ai tendance à envisager
les questions de façon peut-être plus
logique que mes collègues peut-être
après tout les femmes sont elles plus le
jeu plus raisonnable que les hommes dg
tendance également de citer rapidement
les femmes sont dans une famille il faut
prendre des décisions on ne peut pas
d'endroit
mais je n'ai pas les difficultés à être
une femme parfois c'est un peu difficile
quand je me rends compte qu'il y avait
fait qu'il ya certaines solutions entre
laquelle il faut choisir et il faut un
peu de temps à ce que mes collègues se
rallie à mes choix mais ils y arrivent
parce qu'il n'ya pas vraiment d'autre
solution
est ce que vous êtes rendu compte que
votre interview l interview d'une femme
nous sommes rendus compte nous avons
interrogé un premier ministre énergique
en effet c'est exactement ça roule bien
merci beaucoup thank you prime minister
merci nous avoir reçus au 10 downing
street dès maintenant à paris c'est
louis blériot qui vous présente un
question de temps consacré précisément
problèmes de l'agriculture de demain
le pari vert bonsoir
[Musique]